[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es wieder ein Nachgemacht-Video.
Und in meinem letzten Video
oder in einem meiner letzten Videos
– in allen –
habe ich gefragt:
"Was soll ich denn als Nächstes nachmachen?"
Und viele von euch haben geschrieben:
von IKEA diese kleinen Zimtröllchen.
Und die haben wir jetzt hier gefunden.
Ich muss sagen:
Ich habe die noch nie probiert.
Also tatsächlich noch nie.
Und zwar gibt es die einmal als Vanille-
und als Zimtröllchen.
Und die heißen
– hier steht Gifflar.
Natürlich muss ich jetzt erst mal gucken,
wie man das ausspricht.
Denn
Köttbullar, wie viele sagen,
heißt ja auch nicht Köttbullar, sondern Schöttbullar.
Das muss man aber erst alles immer lernen von euch.
Und jetzt habe ich das hier mal gegoogelt.
Ich habe es mir noch nicht angehört.
Achtung.
>> COMPUTER: Jifflar.
>> SALLY: Jifflar.
Da steht sogar: "Aussprache von Pär,"
– das ist irgendwie ein Nutzer –
"männlich, aus Schweden".
>> COMPUTER: Jifflar.
>> SALLY: Jifflar.
Heute gibt es Gifflar
und zwar einmal Vanilla-Gifflar
und einmal Zimt-Gifflar.
Ich muss jetzt aber erst mal wissen, wie es schmeckt.
Ich habe nur eine Packung.
Deswegen schneiden wir es mal so auf.
Und dann
– aber ich schätze mal,
es ist einfach ein Hefeteig.
Wartet. Hier kann man es besser lesen,
was drin ist.
Dann, dann, dann,
wenn man die Sprache kennt.
Hier: "Hefegebäckröllchen mit Cremefüllung
mit Vanillegeschmack".
"Mehl, Zucker, Öl, Hefe, Eier, Stärke" und so weiter.
Aha, aha! "Natürliches Vanillearoma".
Hm.
Übrigens: Wenn irgendwo draufsteht "natürliches Aroma",
dann kann das
– also es muss nur natürlichen Ursprungs sein.
Das heißt, es kann auch sein,
dass zum Beispiel Holzspäne verwendet werden.
Und das ist ja auch natürlichen Ursprungs.
Und dann steht einfach drauf: "natürliches Aroma".
Wie bei Erdbeerjoghurt zum Beispiel.
Okay. Das ist jetzt Vanille.
Warte. Ich mache es mal so auf.
Okay.
Cremig sieht es nicht aus,
aber es riecht gut.
Hätte man das noch erwärmen müssen oder so?
Nee, nicht?
Nö.
Die schmecken trocken.
Aber es ist okay für so ein Fertigprodukt.
Also kauft sie bitte nicht.
Kauft sie einfach nicht bitte. Okay?
Jetzt Zimt.
Ich denke mir, bevor man so was isst,
ganz ehrlich, geht lieber zum Bäcker vor Ort
und unterstützt euren Bäcker vor Ort,
also bevor ich mir so Zimtschnecken
und Vanilleschnecken aus der Tüte kaufe.
Hm, hm.
Kauft die auch nicht.
Ich mache jetzt ein Rezept für euch.
Und wir machen die jetzt selber nach
und zwar so, dass sie besser schmecken.
Okay?
Und vielleicht machen wir sie einmal in normal
und einmal in vegan.
Ich hole schon mal die Zutaten.
Hier habe ich jetzt mal die Zutaten für den Hefeteig gerichtet.
Ich mache jetzt, wie gesagt, einmal eine normale Version
und eine vegane Version.
Im Prinzip unterscheiden die sich
nicht viel.
Also ich habe hier einfach
einen halben Würfel Hefe jeweils,
etwas Zucker und Wasser,
250 Gramm Mehl,
etwas Milch.
Hier habe ich dann Hafermilch stattdessen.
Ein Eigelb habe ich hier
und hier einfach einen Esslöffel Apfelmus, selbst gemacht.
Salz
und Butter.
Oh, ich habe die Butter vertauscht.
Hier ist die normale Butter
und hier ist die vegane Butter.
Also das sind eigentlich die Standardzutaten.
Das heißt, ich bereite jetzt zweimal einen Hefeteig zu.
Ich hole mir ganz kurz eine Küchenmaschine.
Und ihr gebt jetzt einfach die Hefe,
den Zucker und das Wasser in die Rührschüssel.
Ihr könnt den Teig auch mit der Hand verkneten.
Und jetzt gebt ihr einfach die restlichen Zutaten dazu.
Die Milch habe ich ein bisschen erwärmt.
Salz und Butter wirklich immer schön am Ende dazu geben,
damit die Hefe schön aufgehen kann.
Also nicht direkt auf die Hefe geben,
sondern eher dann auf die Butter.
Und jetzt den Teig einfach
für mindestens fünf bis zehn Minuten
schön weich kneten.
[Musik]
Hier ist der Teig und das ist ein richtig schöner weicher Teig,
der aber auch nicht klebt.
Falls er doch ein bisschen klebt,
dann nehmt wirklich ganz, ganz wenig Mehl nur.
Denn er soll wirklich nicht zu fest sein,
sondern eher schön weich.
Ich forme ihn jetzt zu einer Kugel,
weil ich es einfach immer superschön finde.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Und wie gesagt, könnt ihr jetzt beide Teige einfach abdecken
und etwa eine Stunde aufgehen lassen
oder im Backofen,
im Dampfbackofen bei Gärstufe mit Dampfunterstützung.
Da braucht es nur etwa 30 Minuten.
[Musik]
Und im Backofen bei Gärstufe habt ihr auch den Vorteil,
dass der Teig nicht austrocknet an der Oberfläche.
[Musik]
Während der Teig jetzt noch aufgeht,
kann ich schon mal die Vanillefüllung zubereiten.
Die mache ich jetzt für den normalen Hefeteig,
also für den nicht veganen.
Ich nehme jetzt dafür
200 Gramm Schmand,
– ihr könnt aber auch Quark nehmen
oder Crème fraîche oder ein anderes Milchprodukt,
was so ein bisschen fester ist als Milch –
ein Ei,
40 Gramm Zucker,
25 Gramm Stärke
und etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Und dafür verrührt ihr jetzt einfach alle Zutaten.
[Musik]
Für später.
Jetzt einfach alles verrühren.
[Musik]
Bevor das ganze Rezept in einem Schmecksperiment endet,
denn
die Füllung ist leider immer noch zu flüssig,
werde ich sie jetzt doch erwärmen.
Ich wollte eigentlich einen Pudding machen ohne Kochen
und jetzt muss ich doch erwärmen.
Denn, wenn ich diese Masse
so auf den Teig gleich streiche, dann
läuft alles aus.
Also hier kurz die Schmandmasse erwärmen.
Da hätte ich ja auch Milch nehmen können.
Egal.
Das gehört so, damit es cremiger wird.
Jetzt einfach kurz während des Kochens immer rühren
und einfach so lange, bis die Masse eindickt.
Also sie muss nicht unbedingt aufkochen.
Die dickt auch vorher schon ein bisschen ein.
Und dann reicht es.
Bis es eine schöne streichfähige Masse ergibt.
So. Das lasse ich jetzt abkühlen.
Jetzt bereite ich erst einmal die Vanilleschnecken zu.
Die Vanille-Griff-
– Gifflar.
Ich musste kurz gucken.
Vanille-Gifflar.
Jifflar.
Jifflár.
Oje! Sagt mir einfach, wie es heißt.
Ich muss sagen, der Teig ist schön weich.
Und jetzt schön ausrollen,
am besten zu einem langen Strang.
Die Luft!
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt den Teig 60 mal 20 cm groß ausgerollt.
Es wäre natürlich schlauer gewesen,
das so auszurollen.
Denn ich muss es ja gleich aufrollen.
Aber
ich habe es jetzt so gemacht.
So.
Und da kommt jetzt die Füllung rein.
Jetzt schön verteilen.
[Musik]
Also von der Breite her würde ich schon
4 cm machen.
4 cm.
[Musik]
Und hier obendrauf kommt jetzt
eine Mischung aus Eigelb,
etwas Milch und Puderzucker.
Puderzucker einfach,
damit das Ganze einen schönen Glanz bekommt
und schön karamellisiert und braun wird.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kommen die hier direkt in den Backofen.
Ich habe den jetzt gerade angestellt.
Also ihr könnt den auch in den kalten Backofen schieben
und dann den Ofen anmachen.
Ihr könnt sie auch vorher noch aufgehen lassen.
Aber die sind ja so schön klein.
Die müssen eigentlich gar nicht lange aufgehen.
Und jetzt kurz backen.
Und in der Zwischenzeit machen wir schon mal die veganen.
[Musik]
Okay.
Hier ist der vegane Teig.
Und da streiche ich jetzt
– hier mache ich ja jetzt die Zimtschnecken daraus,
die Zimt-Gifflar.
Ich muss jedes Mal da rüber auf die Packung gucken.
Also vegane, weiche Butter oder halbweiche.
Die war noch im Kühlschrank.
Ja.
O Mann! Ich sehe schon
die Kommentare:
"Jetzt dreht sie durch!"
[Musik]
Und dann vermische ich jetzt Zimt und Zucker.
Das da drauf streuen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt auch hier wieder aufrollen
– wenn ich genug
Mehl drunter hätte.
[Musik]
Und jetzt hier wieder schön auf die Naht drauflegen
und dann wieder zurechtschneiden.
[Musik]
Da ich jetzt hier bei den veganen
natürlich kein Ei benutzen kann,
nehme ich jetzt einfach Hafermilch und etwas Zucker,
verrühre das Ganze und bestreiche die so
und gebe die dann auch in den kalten Backofen,
schalte den Ofen an.
Und danach, wenn sie gebacken sind,
werden wir sie verkosten.
[Musik]
Also rein mit euch in den kalten Backofen.
Backofen auf 180°C stellen
und dann backen, bis sie schön goldbraun sind.
Und die Aufheizzeit des Backofens
nutzen die kleinen Zimtschneckchen
als Aufgehzeit.
Und dann gehen sie schön auf und backen gleichzeitig.
Sehr schön.
Guckt euch die mal bitte an.
Und ich habe jetzt noch einen megaguten Tipp für euch.
Und zwar habe ich sie gerade
drei Minuten vor Ende der Backzeit
noch mal mit der Eimischung bestrichen.
Und guckt mal, wie die schön glänzen.
Richtig gut!
Jetzt nehme ich sie raus und lasse sie kurz abkühlen.
[Musik]
Hier ist jetzt schon mal die erste Variante,
die Vanille-Gifflar.
Die gucken jetzt alle schon.
Deswegen kann ich nicht sagen, was was ist.
Murat kann eh kein Englisch.
This is original.
This is
my recipe.
Schatz, kommst du probieren?
>> MURAT: Hm.
Ich finde das immer komisch,
>> SALLY: Sarah!
>> MURAT: wenn sie versucht, den...
>> SALLY: Eigentlich habe ich Sarah gemeint.
>> MURAT: Nein.
Ich finde das immer toll, wenn sie versucht,
den Hauptschüler zu verarschen.
Wo ist denn der Typ mit dem rosa Helm?
>> SALLY: Er wartet gerade noch auf die veganen.
>> MURAT: Ja. Also ich probiere das jetzt mal.
Also...
>> SALLY: Mach nicht immer so.
Weil du schließt uns immer aus.
>> MURAT: Ja, okay. Tut mir leid.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Mach dich nicht so groß.
>> MURAT: Also ich bin nicht doof, ich merke,
was selbst gemacht ist und was industriell hergestellt ist.
>> SALLY: Was?
>> MURAT: This is original.
This is your recipe.
He?
Genau.
Aber ich probiere es. Ich bin ja ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Probiere doch erst mal das.
>> MURAT: Ach so.
Okay. Außerdem ist es noch warm.
>> SALLY: Ja, das ist auch warm.
>> MURAT: Also da müssen wir ja schon richtig blöd sein,
wenn wir das nicht merken.
>> SARAH: Das ist auch warm.
>> SALLY: Ich habe die aufgewärmt.
>> SARAH: Jetzt hast du es verraten!
>> MURAT: Sally...
>> SALLY: Ich hatte sie im Backofen.
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Doch.
>> MURAT: Kaum!
>> SARAH: Ich will es auch anfassen.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte sie eigentlich...
>> MURAT: Hör auf, meine Brötchen anzufassen!
Mein Gott! Wir kommen gerade von einer Pandemie.
So.
Hm.
Man merkt, man schmeckt
– ich merke Industrie.
>> SARAH: Woah!
Oh, ich hasse es.
>> MURAT: Also ist es da unterschiedlich
– von den Zutaten her ist da ein Unterschied?
>> SALLY: Ja, schon.
>> MURAT: Hast du von was weniger oder mehr benutzt?
>> SALLY: Ich hätte bei mir
ein bisschen mehr Zucker reinmachen können.
>> MURAT: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen mehr Zucker in die Füllung
schreibe ich euch ins Rezept.
Aber
ich habe halt jetzt kein E471
>> MURAT: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: oder E500 oder E450.
>> MURAT: Wie? Hast du E500 vergessen?
Wie kann man E647 vergessen?
>> SALLY: Oder E202, E282.
>> MURAT: Mein Gott!
>> SALLY: E101, E160a und E330 war halt aus.
>> MURAT: Na ja, ich war...
>> SALLY: Deswegen habe ich das nicht.
>> MURAT: Übrigens immer, wenn ich in den Supermarkt
gehe, kriege ich eine Einkaufsliste.
Sie sagt immer: "Kauf mir bitte E604, E708, E900."
>> SALLY: Nee. Aber man muss dazu sagen,
um jetzt mal das Produkt auch in Schutz zu nehmen
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: – ich will es jetzt ja nicht haten oder so.
>> SALLY: Kaufen müsst ihr es trotzdem nicht.
Aber man muss ja auch so ein Produkt haltbar machen,
damit es eben in so einer Tüte
verkaufsfertig nicht eben nur einen Tag haltbar ist,
sondern wirklich ein paar Wochen.
>> MURAT: Oder Monate.
>> SALLY: Deswegen muss man halt
>> MURAT: Wie lange ist das haltbar?
>> SALLY: muss man halt was dazu geben.
Und es ist Recyclingpapier.
Ah ja.
Bis nächsten Monat.
>> MURAT: Ah.
>> SARAH: Klar.
>> MURAT: Jetzt zeige ich euch mal den Typ,
der gerne in IKEA einkaufen geht.
Genau so sieht er aus.
Da nimmt er seinen Helm mit.
Mit seinem Helm.
Der ist übrigens auch noch Veganer.
Es könnte was passieren in der Küche.
>> DENNIS: Ja, Sicherheit geht vor.
>> SALLY: Da kann er sich durchboxen.
>> DENNIS: Arbeitssicherheit muss hier
jetzt gewährleistet sein.
Und deswegen müssen wir einen Hut
– einen Helm tragen.
>> SARAH: Einen Hut!
>> DENNIS: Also nicht einen Hut, aber einen Helm.
>> SALLY: Also hier noch mal zum Vergleich, Murat.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Die sind vegan.
>> DENNIS: Okay.
>> SALLY: Aber heiß.
>> DENNIS: Oh!
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> DENNIS: Die sind echt heiß.
>> MURAT: Du aber...
>> SARAH: Können wir kurz darüber reden,
dass das wie Cini Minis schmeckt?
>> SALLY & MURAT & DENNIS: Ja.
>> MURAT: Aber ehrlich!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Oh! Können wir mal Cini Minis machen?
>> SARAH: Oh ja!
>> DENNIS: Hm, hm.
>> SARAH: Cini Minis, gell?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Entschuldigung, dass ich echt was sagen muss.
Aber mir kommt es vor,
als würden die veganen am besten schmecken.
>> DENNIS: Ja.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> DENNIS: Warum?
>> SARAH: Oha!
>> SALLY: Weil Zimt drin ist.
>> DENNIS: Weil vegan gut ist.
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Und...
>> SARAH: Weil mehr Zucker und mehr Zimt
und mehr Butter drin ist.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Echt?
>> SALLY: Also das Einzige, was mich bei denen stört, ist,
>> SARAH: Willst du nichts dazu sagen?
>> SALLY: dass der Glanz fehlt.
>> DENNIS: Habe ich gerade schon.
>> SALLY: Also der Glanz auf der Oberfläche fehlt,
aber, mein Gott, dann fehlt er halt.
>> SARAH: Also ich finde auch vegan
>> MURAT: Vegan ist richtig cool.
>> SALLY: Tasting.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SARAH: das beste.
>> MURAT: Cool.
Also
>> SALLY: Ich finde die auch am besten.
>> MURAT: macht's gut! Macht's besser!
>> DENNIS: Team Vegan forever!
>> SALLY: Team Vegan!
>> MURAT: Und macht es selber!
>> SALLY: Und schreibt gerne,
was ich als Nächstes nachmachen soll.
>> MURAT: Ich gehe weiter.
>> SALLY: Tschüss, Murat! Tschüss!
>> DENNIS: Geh mit Gott! Du kriegst bald Besuch.
>> SARAH: Den schon.
>> SALLY: Tschau, Murat!
>> DENNIS: Tschau!
>> SARAH: Die veganen sind woah!
>> DENNIS: Die sind echt gut.
>> SALLY: Und die? Mh.
>> SARAH: Das schmeckt wie früher,
wenn man Cini Minis so gestapelt hat.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Kennst du das?
So ein Sandwich habe ich gemacht.
>> DENNIS: Ich war aber nicht Team Cini Minis.
>> SARAH: Doch, ich schon.
>> DENNIS: Ich war Team Smacks.
>> SALLY: Die sind aber auch gut, nur zu wenig Zucker.
>> SARAH: Ich nehme alle.
>> DENNIS: Team Smacks war einfach...
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen mehr.
>> DENNIS: Woah! Woah, habt ihr mich erschreckt, ey!
Woah!
[Musik]